tra bruce springsteen che vodafone
vodafone barcaccia tutte le volte che
chiami qua a [ __ ] porca [ __ ] ma
mi sembra normale allora l tutti uomini
e donne maria de filippi e benvenuti a
questo nuovo io sono felice oggi siamo
tornati sul raid di ava your lover
la cosa bella di questo gioco è che
chiunque l'abbia fatto che un [ __ ]
genio sta continuando ad aggiornarlo e
ci sono sempre cose nuove voglio vedere
stavolta che cosa esce fuori per chi non
lo sapesse per l'ennesima volta è il
gioco dove devi avere culo
non dovevi prendermi alla lettera frate
devo indovinare quale tra queste due
cose è la più cercata su google tipo il
colosso di rodi c a 49.000 ricerche
mentre per yacht che sarebbe il ciclo
posso capire che la posizione sia più o
meno la stessa e per carità di dio che
sarà la cosa più bella visto gioco
quando fanno dei paragoni che non
c'entrano un cazzo facciamo period è lo
sapevo il labirinto del fauno credo
periodo che rialzino e non di molto è
stica anche lui c'è il periodo che va
dalle mani il periodo labirinto del
fauno and shiney o questo è un cazzo di
paragone decente tutti e due abbastanza
conosciuti secondo me shining shining
grandissimo stephen king e di stephen
king shining 9 che stava figura di merda
sono tra giudaismo e te condor giudaismo
stavo scherzando pro state calmi non mi
menate siamo arrivati a 4 ore che posso
farci trarre di toyota minchia toyota ma
sto scherzando lower purché c'era anche
molti ne alla toyota athletics e martin
luther king athletics sto scherzando tra
discriminazione e moscow news
vabbè teatro ragazzi se io bevo moscow
news
mi ritrovo in cambogia nudo al contrario
non a me è successo purtroppo non di
trovarmi in cambogia ma mi è successo di
bere un moscone vi un novero di quei nel
caso mi imita st cena facciamo di scream
bonus discriminazione è vero che tutti
si ubriacano però dovrò aspettare a
[ __ ]
niente ragazzi delle entrarmi in testa
che in questo mondo di alcolizzati non
mi entra family tree e clash of clans
voglio solo vedere quanti milioni
facciamo tipo 21 no scusami non volevo
offendere ti stai proprio calmo ma calmo
track leisure clan
taci ma lo facciamo pleasure clans mi sa
che non sono quasi convinto porca
[ __ ] ma mi sembra normale allora
allora tashima ralla è più di pai
taj mahal
ma veramente che cazzo robinson stata
2000 20.000 voi cazzo basta 2 milioni di
paia così tanto scusa zio anche te non
ti volevo offendere un volevo offendere
nessuno e oggi a parte king st foto la
tizia sembra che ci abbia le ascelle
santo iddio con la foresta tra requiem
for a dream e australian open credo sara
lee ann open
porca [ __ ] tra bruce springsteen ge
vodafone vodafone marcaccio tutte volte
richiami [ __ ] tra the jacksons
microsoft word e arriviamo a 10 cosa
cazzo fincato cliccato
no non è vero ma non è ma come cazzo
fate a cliccare indietro se io premo il
tasto destro appare indietro avanti ok
come cazzo si è finito su indietro anche
cliccando come bussia e ho cliccato pure
sinistro sto mouse mica è una tragedia
ogni a keynes lite rio vicano lancio e
va indietro con le pagine è indemoniato
sta mica di maso non si capisce tra
paypal rete conto che il plesso clan si
fa più ricerca di paypal tra paypal e
betty boop paypal
mi sembra ovvio betty boop chi se l'è in
gola siamo ritornati a nove ragazzi tra
bellezza e eurovision eurovision ok
perfetto giusto 10 euro vision o
illuminati illuminati penso che poi non
lo so
grazie a dio esistono illuminati e
russia questa l'abbinamento più ingiusto
della storia per renderlo ancora più
abbinato io al posto del dance ci
metterebbero putin
adesso sì che abbina tizio secondo me
russia però ne son sicuro è [ __ ]
vt che va al reagan ci credo chris brown
e ancora sto colosso di rodi ma per che
cosa c'è colosso di rodi oggi è fame
team il ciclo ti prego crepe più o meno
la colosso di rodi e winnie the pooh che
più o meno come il ciclo winnie the pooh
ok dai adesso prova indovinare quante
con tette però non hanno messo
l'immagine delle tette perché ovviamente
non si poteva si promette solo 500.000
sono solo mie com'è possibile umanità mi
stai stupendo hong kong e al di cazzo e
al di che cazzo è al deal di nel senso
che non è uno ma sono due va bene è un
re un market di cibo e vabbè ma neanche
una volta in vita mia l'ho sentito mai
ci siamo ragazzi sono tornati a 12 più o
meno adesso stavo per perdere in questo
momento ma vabbè beckenbauer e hotel
ruanda hot air one da per pochissimo
stiamo andando veramente al limite bret
hart
ma grazie a dio 14 ragazze the walking
dead facciamo una stima di the walking
dead secondo me the walking dead arriva
tipo a 2 milioni e 450 caso camino tozza
tra the walking dead e body ott se non è
puzza di più lui che la tipa è comunque
va be the walking dead sicuro siamo a
sedici ragazzi a 16 il mio record e 17
tra body horror e fede fedex sicuro 6
milioni ok fedex ovviamente c'è un cazzo
in confronto mai così ma sorveglianza
jan real madrid vai così 19 è la madonna
19 real madrid john lewis michiara
madrid
porca [ __ ] ragazzi siamo arrivati a 20
record mondiale di aicarr lower alla
john lewis e maldive credo john lewis
ok maldive e seul
minchiate un [ __ ] a corea così nel
topo dell'un per cento di tutti i
giocatori alla madonna grazie 21 non lo
fa nessuno ragazzi non lo farà anche
l'un per cento le app della gente che
gioca sta roba che vedete
vita passata a sostare la baia è servita
a qualcosa adesso sì che sono fiero di
me stesso
proviamo l'ultima volta dai ragazzi
visto che sono andato così bene siccome
non posso concludere un video in cui ho
fatto una bella figura chiudiamolo
facendo un punteggio di merda così siamo
a posto ovviamente prince è infatti tra
tom hanks e mike tyson
mike tyson ok rapprende ancora sto
prosecco ma perché prosecco ma che cosa
c'è la gente col prosecco prosecco
[ __ ] prosecco adesso mi ero fidato
su gli alcolizzati e non ha funzionato
allora andate a cagare avere ragazzi
concludo vile episodio di tiger lauer
stavolta ha battuto il record più di 21
e difficilissimo ha sputato
meglio dell'un per cento della
popolazione wow è ovvio che io sia
meglio dell'un per cento nel fare
minchiate quindi ragazzi spero che sia
piaciuto concludo che l'episodio 100.000
like solo per il record ma solo per
quello e quindi ragazzi spero che il
video vi sia piaciuto a cosa è piaciuto
un commento è un mi piace anche la
pagina di facebook che come nei piloti
schizzi anni 60 si fischia 13
picchiavano prossimo video e speriamo mi
sentivo in dovere scusa ed io non volevo
fare bella ragazza